[Music]
from JJ Abrams the visionary behind Star
Wars Episode seven and felicity comes a
reboot impossible not to enjoy
unless you're William Shatner Star Trek
the cool new franchise that used
time-travel gobbledygook to throw away
50 years of Ganon but who cares
cuz Star Trek is awesome again meet Nero
ha
a Romulan out for vengeance after his
home planet is destroyed he'll be given
a second chance to save his species when
a black hole sends him back in time but
instead of warning his planet about
their impending doom he'll drift around
waiting in space for 25 years come on
they don't have phones in space but
there's one man who can stop him
Captain Pike who was quickly captured
leaving only one other man commander
Spock who quits after an emotional
breakdown there have been emotionally
compromised leaving only one other other
man who can stop it
Captain James T curve an angry drunk who
is accepted into Starfleet without any
paperwork background checks or medical
evaluations come aboard as Kirk commands
the USS Enterprise the Federation's
heavily armed apple store
of black geniuses who rise through the
ranks
not because of service or aptitude but
because of things like the flu for his
helmsman McKenna he has long warm sir
I'm yukata sooner death doctor poori was
on deck 6 he's dead and you have just
inherited his responsibility as chief
medical officer gross incompetence sir
I'm not sure I can distinguish the
Romulan language from Vulcan before
believe the lieutenant and sheer
proximity to a clean uniform experience
a film that made nerds cry nerds cheer
and nerds go explore a brand-new Star
Trek universe that takes all the Star
Trek aliens you know and love and
doesn't show any of them instead witness
big eyes long face tic-tac eyes and tan
MA
prepare to be blown away by what was
essentially JJ Abrams Star Wars demo
reel
it's a saga that asks all the important
questions like why does Chris Pine make
the same stupid face every time he gets
purged and oh we know the riders still
working so blast off into a new era of
actually watchable Star Trek films
filled with action excitement and glands
flares
[Music]
and even more flares
seriously how can anyone even see on
this ship
starring sad Branigan spork
oh my space nakiri Mike Tyson no one's
favorite Keith Urban groundskeeper
Willie Tyler Perry's Tyler Perry and old
sport star Trey
man that was cool so how long until they
reboot next generation man that is gonna
be radical thanks for watching be sure
to subscribe I didn't choose the thug
life the thug life chose me my voice
gives me super strength
chickadee China the Chinese chicken get
in the chopper do it now I woke up in a
new Bugatti